Obviously, we have to talk about gun control
this week.
Over the course of our many Rubin Report interviews,
I've sat across from an array people who are
pro-gun rights, anti-gun altogether, or somewhere
in between.
While the events surrounding the gun conversation
are always horrific...with this week's tragic
events in Vegas being perhaps the worst of
them all...I believe the conversation around
guns, when done right, can offer powerful
insight into how people think about society
at large.
Gun ownership and the right to bear arms brings
up issues about the American constitution,
states rights, personal responsibility, mental
health, radicalization...both religious and
otherwise...and much more.
Unfortunately, as is the case so often these
days, we're seemingly caught between two groups:
the people who want to ban guns completely,
and the people who don't want to have any
sort of conversation about sensible gun laws.
While I absolutely support the 2nd Amendment,
at the same time I absolutely acknowledge
the United States has what seems to be a unique
problem related to mass gun violence.
Lost in the midst of the awful events of Last
Vegas this week are the other senseless shootings
across the country, like the 5 people killed
and 30 others wounded by gun fire in Chicago
this past weekend.
The weekend before that, 3 were killed and
36 wounded in Chicago, and the weekend before
that it was 11 dead and 29 wounded in the
very same city.
We've included a link down below which tracks
the gun related violence across Chicago occurring
every single weekend, and it's disturbing
to say the least.
I bring up Chicago not to deflect from the
events in Las Vegas, but to show this murderous
violence is happening in one of our biggest
cities literally every single day, happening
so often at this point the mainstream media
has all but given up on reporting on it.
The reasons behind how and why people murder
others also makes it hard to find one law
around guns that works in every situation.
There no doubt is a difference between a murder
that occurs during a robbery v. gang violence
v. terrorism v. suicides v. a random shooter
with no known political or religious motive.
And the same time, there are the times when
someone with a gun saves innocent lives during
a shoot-out, or when someone defends their
property and family by having a gun in the
home.
So again, while I support the 2nd Amendment,
I also recognize that we undoubtably have
a gun-related violence problem on our hands...just
look at the numbers.
I can also acknowledge that guns in and of
themselves aren't the only problem here.
Without question, much of the carnage caused
by guns is due to people with mental health
issues gaining access to guns.
The truth is that if I, or most the gun owners
in America, had access to the most deadly
weapons on Earth, we wouldn't randomly use
those weapons against innocent people.
Not only are mental health issues an aspect
to the people who commit mass shootings, but
also there is also a problem with any ideology
which drives people to commit these heinous
acts, be it a religious ideology, a political
ideology, or any other system of principals
or beliefs which could drive someone to kill.
A weapon in and of itself can't kill anyone,
it takes a human being and a corrupt thought
process to pull the trigger and kill innocent
people.
Also, as I'm recording this, it is still unclear
exactly what weapons were used in Vegas, but
authorities report finding about 20 other
fire arms in the shooter's hotel room, and
it's possible that this man was using a military
style fully automatic rifle to commit this
heinous act.
For all the defense I've offered the 2nd Amendment,
I CAN NOT see how access to such weapons,
which have the ability to mow down civilians
at an incredible rate and which are designed
for the battlefield, should be in the hands
of regular citizens.
As we post this video the story about the
Vegas gunman is largely incomplete.
At the moment we don't seem to know his motives,
so it's hard to say if this was an act of
terrorism under the most specific definition
of the term, which includes having a political
motivation to kill.
Nevada state’s defintion is a little more
broad, not including the need for a political
motivation, which would in fact classify this
killer as a Terrorist.
Regardless of how we want to define this specific
act of horrific violence, or how the gun discussion
relates to terrorism, or the legitimate right
of every citizen to have the ability defend
themselves, we must get better about talking
about gun control between the shootings in
order to prevent more shootings, and not just
when these acts occur.
Passing more laws in the heat of emotion is
rarely the right thing to do, even if they
are well intentioned, while doing nothing
and hoping these events will simply end is
just as misguided as hoping terrorism will
completely stop if we just ignore it.
While we wait to find out more about the Vegas
shooter himself and at the same time mourn
the victims of this evil act, we should also
continue to talk to people on both sides of
the gun debate to try to come to sensible
place of agreement.
I'm going to do my best to do just that -- if
you know of some interesting voices in this
debate you'd like to hear on The Rubin Report,
let us know in the comment section right down
below.